bonjour messieurs merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france à l'heure
laurent alexandre j'ai tout d'abord
m'adresser à vous quelle est votre
position sur ce pas ça ni terre
fallait-il le mettre en place à l'heure
actuelle en france
j'écris et quelques jours une tribune
proposant la vaccination obligatoire
pour les soignants mais pas la
vaccination obligatoire pour la totalité
de la population
je pensais qu'on pouvait attendre
jusqu'à la fin de l'été avant d'imposer
la vaccination obligatoire comme
emmanuel macron la dé facto imposé
puisque on ne pourra plus rien faire si
l'on n'est pas vacciné et que de serre
15 pcr par mois ou même qu'un ce test
quand ils génique
ce n'est pas une vie ce n'est pas
envisageable donc en réalité il ya une
vraie vaccination obligatoire
l'apposition du président se défend de
vouloir imposer la vaccination à tous
voient une l'immense majorité des plus
de 12 ans devraient être efficaces pour
éviter des couvre-feux et des mesures
liberticides à petit feu pendant encore
une année
une position qui se défend bien sûr qui
a ses détracteurs mais elle a sa logique
même si moi à titre personnel je n'étais
pas partisan de cette obligation j'étais
partisan de se donner un petit peu le
temps de la conviction avant la
coalition entend un pêcheur ça veut dire
quoi concrètement que nous aurons en
france les personnes disposant d'un pass
sanitaire qui pourront entrer dans des
établissements et d'un côté les autres
qui ne pourront pas certains parlent de
discrimination
est-ce que ça s'y apparente selon vous
alors écoutez déjà lé 7 cette loi n'est
pas passée donc il y a encore pour ceux
qui ne sont pas d'accord pour cette
obligation n'en voit pas la logique qui
n'envoient pas l'efficacité
un espoir eux le conseil des apports
d'un avis très défavorable à cette loi
que le sénat puisse voter contre cette
loi qui
on s'entend sur liste est parfaitement
liberticide puisque cette obligation
d'avoir un pass vaccinale est une forme
indirecte contraintes et de restriction
des libertés notamment de la liberté
d'aller et venir qui la preuve une des
premières libertés fondamentales chez
nous il ya encore cet espoir que cette
loi ne passe pas la question sera porté
vraisemblablement bientôt devant le
conseil d'état dans des procès juridique
elle sera aussi traitée sans doute à un
niveau international
et là où la question sur eddy est un t6
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir semble-t-il
et et les nouvelles cette question c'est
de savoir si on peut obliger
l'intégralité la population d'un pays à
se faire vacciner avec un médicament qui
dispose pour le moment et jusqu'en 2023
une autorisation provisoire est
conditionnel de mise sur le marché
ça pose un réel problème juridique
la question a beaucoup de sens on est en
effet les conséquences politiques d'une
telle décision d'une telle loi serait de
cristalliser le débat de la stratégie
pour se débarrasser de cet ennemi commun
qui est un véritable monstre et je pense
que là dessus tout le monde est d'accord
la question de cette stratégie doit
faire l'objet d'un débat et ceux qui
résistent contre les atteintes aux
libertés qui ont à mon sens raison de se
battre doivent être entendus dans ce
qu'ils disent ce ne sont pas des anti
fax ce sont des gens qui se posent des
questions et à ces questions il faut des
réponses
on a aujourd'hui laurent alexandre à
cette extension du pass anita finalement
c'est parce qu'il n'ya pas assez de
france
vacciner est-ce que selon vous le
gouvernant a échoué donc sa stratégie de
communication pourquoi n'at-il pas
réussi à convaincre les français d'aller
se faire vacciner
ce n'est pas facile de faire vacciner
une population
regardez les statistiques russes une
infime minorité de la population russe
est vaccinée poutine est pourtant un
homme de conviction un homme fort un
homme qui en général entraîne sa
population mais il a échoué sur le
vaccin
le taux de vaccination en russie est le
plus faible de tout l'hémisphère nord
donc vous voyez ça n'est pas si simple
que ça donc devant cette situation là on
a aujourd'hui deux possibilités soit on
maintient des couvre feux
régulièrement on referme les restaurants
les boîtes de nuit à partir de fin ou
disques en novembre soit on casse le
noeud gordien et on impose la
vaccination
on n'a plus beaucoup de choix parmi les
gens qui étaient présents en première
ligne et que j'ai vu tout à l'heure sur
vos images
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
sont des proses ivermectine et qui
pensent qu'il y à des traitements qui
peuvent remplacer la vaccination et
notamment l'étude de pasteur qui a été
très abondamment retweeter par filippo
par dupont aignan est partout les gens
étaient en première ligne de la
manifestation à paris cet après-midi ont
oublié de dire que cette étude concerne
18 hamster et donne des résultats qui
sont statistiquement totalement
insignifiant et qui n'ont aucun intérêt
dans l'espèce humaine et que la grande
étude égyptienne qui était en faveur de
l'ivermectine a été retiré pour fraude
majeure les résultats ont été inventés
par les auteurs de cette étude est donc
l'arrêter ce qu'on n'a pas de traitement
donc en pratique si on veut être
raisonnable soit on va vers la bastille
la vaccination massive soit
et ben on referme les restaurants dans
pas beaucoup de semaines parce que le
dans le delta il est vraiment explosif
quand vous regardez attentivement les
chiffres hollande
le nombre de contaminations journalières
il a été multiplié par 10 en quelques
jours
cet explosif la catalogne est en
catastrophe centrale
tours servait donc on n'a pas beaucoup
de choix aujourd'hui on ne va pas passer
des vacances tranquilles si on ne sait
pas un immense pas en avant en matière
de vaccination
donc la position du gouvernement réduit
nos libertés bien sûr mais un état
régalien diminue la liberté dans de
nombreux cas sommes obligés de mettre
notre ceinture de sécurité par exemple
donc ce n'est pas une nouveauté il y a
plein de vaccins obligatoires et jadis
la vaccination contre la variole était
obligatoire pour tout le monde
et d'ailleurs c'est ça qui a permis à
l'échelle mondiale d' éradiquer la
variole en 1977
entendant pêcheurs c'est beaucoup revenu
tout au long de la journée avec nous
inviter la logistique en toute la
logistique d'air se passe
le gouvernement va-t-il demander au
restaurant bar au café de contrôler un
se passa ni terre et s'ils le font mal
pourront-ils être jugé responsable
alors pour répondre à votre dernière
question absolument la loi le projet loi
comprenez prévoit une sanction pénale
extrêmement lourde pour les défauts de
contrôle dans les restaurants et la
question surtout et je vais rebondir
pour y répondre à ce qu'a dit le docteur
la différence entre porter une ceinture
de sécurité et sauf et respecter un
produit qui n'a pas terminé la phase de
test c'est que vous avez une défiance
pauvre démocratie
la question de l'adhésion voilà des
citoyens aux règles qui leur sont
proposés essentiel autrement alors pour
utiliser des grands mots mais en 3 600
le trait évidemment c'est le début en
effet deux d'un régime qui aura les
aspects d'une démocratie autoritaire
ça c'est un fait indéniable
politiquement philosophiquement la
question de l'adhésion aux règles est
essentiel donc la stratégie de
communication du gouvernement a échoué
et on peut le dire puisque les français
ne comprennent plus rien quand on leur
dit ne fait pas d'eux
fête d'été porter des masques ne porte
ne portait pas de masque porter des
masques
c'est incompréhensible et forcément on
perd la confiance des citoyens
là où la stratégie n'a pas fonctionné
c'est le gouvernement qui en est à
l'origine
le fait de transférer or plus les
contrôles qui est là un pouvoir régalien
sur la tête des restaurateurs c'est
quelque chose de parfaitement aberrant
aberrant seuls les policiers peuvent
contrôler seuls les forces de l'ordre
peuvent contrôler les citoyens comment
vivre dans un monde vous dites monsieur
qu'il y aura des couvre-feux des
couvre-feux je n'en suis pas sûr dans
toutes les guerres parce que nous sommes
en guerre là tu emmanuel macron a raison
nous sommes en guerre contre un virus
dans toutes les formes de guerre s'il
n'y a pas une seule forme de résistance
il y en a eu plusieurs
l'idée d'une résistance monolithique et
une la solution stratégique dans le
cadre d'une guerre et inintelligible est
inintelligente il faut diversifier les
solutions et emporter l'adhésion de la
population
écoutez les résistances qui ne sont que
des questions qu'on pose donc c'est pour
moi citoyens démocrates républicains
une aberration totale est inacceptable
que de transférer sur la tête et de
certains citoyens la responsabilité de
contrôler les autres citoyens
alexandre donner le droit de réponse
très rapidement parce qu'on est pressé
par le temps
oui bien sûr moi ce que j'observe en
gardant la manifestation c'est qu'on est
à l'extrême extrême extrême droite parmi
tous ces gens qui manifestent
ça n'est pas représentatif de la cid de
la population française
on efface là j'ai bien regardé dans les
trois premiers rangs il y avait la fine
fleur des complotistes anti-vaccins des
complotistes pro ivermectine etc etc
donc prétendre que il y a là un front
uni contre la dictature macro nist
serait excessif
moi j'ai vu un quarteron de leader
complotistes de l'extrême extrême droite
bien bien à droite du rassemblement
national qui d'ailleurs n'a pas pris
parti dans cette manifestation
mais on n'a pas vu les en douter de
toutes les personnes qui étaient là
cette manifestation mais évidemment on a
vu en tout cas des images il y avait des
milliers de personnes on ne peut pas
savoir en tout cas ne veut pas dire pour
l'instant
de quel parti ils sont ils sont pas j'en
connais je connais je connais pas mal et
je peux vous dire que c'était pour une
grosse majorité des gens à l'extrême
extrême droite bien bien bien à droite
du rassemblement national
en tout cas c'est un argument dès le ces
manifs les fraises compter au corps
était à la fois en dehors de certaines
que certains groupes d'extrême droite ça
qui se retrouve en première ligne et
vous n'avez vu que trois personnes qui
ont été hyper lookée mois au premier
rang j'ai aussi vu mon confrère enfin
d'estivé duo excellent avocat très bien
renseignés très bien documenté quelqu'un
d'extrêmement sérieux qui n'a rien à
part avec l'extrême droite
seulement aux gens et production se sont
rassemblés qui aurait moi-même été
affirmé que je suis très loin des idées
de l'exploit j aurais loin même été si
vous n'avez pas eu la possibilité de
venir témoigner aujourd'hui sur cette
chaîne que je vous remercie pour
l'invitation
et encore vous vous trompez ou clés
l'inde arguments complètement
irrecevables et non pardon mais stupide
pour faire croire que convalescents
thomas p charme et à punir son propos ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas l'extrême droite
y est dans cette manifestation il ya des
milliers et des milliers et des milliers
de personnes monsieur qui ne sont
absolument pas représentatif de
l'extrême droite et qui simplement eu
l'opportunité de manifester dans une un
rassemblement autorisé ce qui évite les
heurts avec les fortes lente mais c'est
normal mais c'est absolument pas
l'extrême droite qui vient manifester la
science aussi ont des soucis en tout cas
pour remettre les choses dans son
contexte les gens qui manifestent
aujourd'hui on avait des invités tout au
long de la journée ne sont pas anti
vaccins ils sont bien juste anti pas
sanitaire l'union brillant contre la
vaccination est plutôt contre cette
forme de contrainte parce que laurent
alexandre est ce que selon vous ce n'est
pas un peu une manière déguisée nous
l'avions dit de toute façon au début de
votre propos
pas sanitaires à ce que c'est pas une
manière de rendre la vaccination
obligatoire finalement pour tous les
français dès 12 ans ce n'est pas une
façon déguisée de rendre la vaccination
obligatoire
c'est une façon parfaitement explicite
et assumée de rendre la vaccination
obligatoire donc la vaccination est
obligatoire sinon on ne peut pas avoir
une vie normale dans la france d'août et
septembre 2021 et c'est assumé par le
président c'est pas du tout déguisées ça
n'est pas du tout une façon cachée
d'exiger la vaccination c'est une façon
vraiment totalement assumé je m'excuse
de revenir sur le point qu'on a vu dans
les trois premiers rangs il y avait
également la fine fleur des anti vaccins
et j'en ai reconnu beaucoup parce que
j'ai débattu avec beaucoup d'anti vaccin
ces derniers mois donc il n'est pas vrai
de dire que c'est représentatif de toute
la société française est d'ailleurs une
large majorité des français dans les
sondages sont sortis ces quatre derniers
jours ont montré qu'il y avait adhésion
aux propositions favorisant la
vaccination tous azimuts des français au
premier rang vous ne me dirais pas que
vous avez vu tous les partis de france
ce n'est pas vrai il n'y avait parmi les
militants politiques parmi les têtes de
gondole il n'y avait que des gens
d'extrême droite qui tonnaient la
banderole je ne dis pas que tout le
monde était d'extrême droite et je ne me
permettrais pas de qualifier division
d'extrémistes de droite
moi je parle des politiciens et il n'est
pas très difficile de voir que ces
politiciens sont des politiciens
d'extrême droite
il n'y avait pas de leaders de gauche en
tête de gondole ce n'est pas vrai c'est
factuellement faux quand on a un bon
sens alors merci de donner la
possibilité de répondre je n'ai pas dit
qu'il y avait la gauche sort en tête de
ce cortège
néanmoins ce que mobilité et les
intéressements parce que qu'est-ce que
ça signifie
politiquement monsieur ça signifie que
parce que les français sont favorables à
ces mesures simplement parce que on nous
dit que le vaccin sera obligatoire pour
les soignants ski et intuitivement
rassurant en effet néanmoins d'après les
chiffres que j'aime vous vous en vous en
connaissez plus que moi le vaccin
diminuerait d'après les études
empiriques qui ont été réalisés
notamment celle de la grande bretagne de
50% de la possibilité de transmettre la
maladie
or le fait de porter un masque ffp2
limite à 95 sont le fait de pouvoir
transmettre la maladie
donc la stratégie n'est absolument pas
la bonne c'est de l'enfumage politique
et l'unicité de la méthode pour rebondir
à ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
sur les formes de résistance n'est pas à
féliciter
il faut nous permettre d'adhérer à des
stratégies différentes divers
diversifiée car la pire des situations
docteur sa trêve nous dira dans quelques
années quelques mois ou quelques années
nous nous sommes trompés nous avons
tellement juger l'histoire il faut nous
méfier car l'histoire va nous juger
et nous avons une responsabilité envers
elle quand on est avocat au barreau de
paris laurent alexandre est essayiste et
m6 revient merci à vous deux messieurs
d'abord participé à ce débat et rappelle
qu'ils avaient également françois ruffin
de gaulle qui avait appelé en tout cas
aujourd'hui à manifester pour remettre
les choses dans leur contexte merci à
vous deux messieurs d'avoir été avec
nous aujourd'hui